ce
bonjour
alors vous venez d'entendre jean marc
j'espère que ça vous a plu et pour ne
rien vous cacher je suis comme jean-marc
je n'aime pas beaucoup les téléphones
alors j'ai une petite question qu'on
commence et qui est venu sans téléphone
à la grande question à ya quand même une
personne à deux pas mal ah non ça ça
compte pas donc les téléphones c'est une
longue histoire compliquée avec moi et
la dernière conversation téléphonique
que j'ai eu c'est avec ma soeur qui me
disait je t'ai appelé 30 fois dans la
journée tu n'as jamais décrocher je t'ai
envoyé trois sms tu ne réponds pas c'est
quoi ton problème avec les téléphones et
donc je vous aimais petite photo un
téléphone c'est une batterie de la
connectique de l'électronique des
petites lampes un téléphone c'est du
mercure du plomb du lithium des
matériaux cancérigène des matériaux
toxiques pour l'environnement sans
parler de ceux qui seront épuisés dans
quelques années
alors vous avez compris je n'aime pas
les téléphones mais là il est presque
midi vous vous dit ouh là là là là ça y
est elle va nous gonfler on a faim
pourquoi alors je vous rassure j'ai pas
toujours été écolo
au contraire même au début j'étais
chimiste une raison simple
voyez tous ces pêcheurs ces petites
fioles ces ballons il ya plein de
couleurs
et c'est juste au fun c'est coloré ça
sent bon on peut faire exploser des
trucs la chimie c'est bien et donc c'est
comme ça que je recommence j'apparais en
métropole j'intègre une école de chimie
et de fil en aiguille je passe les
étapes et tout et je pars en stage dans
une usine qui fabrique des engrais alors
des engrais pour la culture des petits
grains bleus et le stage est en
laboratoire de contrôle qualité
alors le contrôle qualité mais ces dames
c'est simple ce sont des analyses
physiques et chimiques
tous les matins je reçois un petit pot
de deux d'engrais en fait en engrais en
grimpant dans des des grès en fait que
j'analyse donc contrôle physique du
hanté taille des grains couleurs des
graines diamètre voilà tout ce qui est
basique et puis des analyses chimiques
les analyses chimiques donc le ph la
solubilité la concentration en matière
active
le seul petit souci c'est que cette
usine
elle ne fabrique qu'un seul produit de
l'engrais et donc c'est parti pour un
stage de trois mois où je fais les mêmes
analyses tous les jours de 8h à 18h
alors vous avez deviné je m'ennuie comme
un rat mort pendant trois mois ça va
être difficile
mon maître de stage qui est quand même
finalement assez futé
s'en rend compte et m'a dit qu'est ce
qui se passe je te sens plus très
motivés qu'est ce qui s'est passé donc
là je lui parle franchement je lui dis
bon écoutez c'est bien j'ai acquis de la
technique mais tous les jours je me vois
pas vraiment faire ça tous les jours
donc comment on fait et mon maître de
stage à l'époque et référent
environnement et il m'a dit écoute je
m'occupe de l'environnement sur l' usine
est ce que tu as envie de bosser aussi
sur cet aspect pendant son stage à ce
moment là messieurs dames
l'environnement jeu m'a dit ouh là de
quoi il me parle j'y connais pas grand
chose mais au point où j'en suis je pas
grand chose à perdre vous êtes d'accord
avec moi je m'ennuie
tant qu'à faire je suis obligé de faire
ce stage au temps de travailler sur
autre chose
je commence par travailler avec lui sur
tout ce qui est nuisance de lusine
nuisances sonores tout ce qui va être
émissions dans l'air et ensuite petit à
petit et je découvre les impacts que les
engrais ont sur l'environnement alors là
je vous ai mis une jolie photo vous
voyez l'eau et toute verte l'engrais
utilisé en dosage
on va dire pas adapté donc trop
d'engrais dans les sols ça passe dans
l'eau la pluie lessive les engrais et
les emmènent dans la merde et on a des
merdes comme ça vous imaginez vous allez
aux salines lots et toute verte qui se
mène pas moi c'est j'ai envie de dire
que c'est la première fois que j'ai
vraiment eu un choc
par rapport à nos impacts sur
l'environnement là je me suis dit waouh
on a vraiment nos activités en fait on
vraiment un impact concret sur notre
environnement et je décide quelque part
j'ai pas encore pris la décision de
changer d'orientation mais je sais qu'il
faut que je foule
il faut que je cherche la deuxième chose
qui m'interpelle
c'est ce monsieur alors à votre avis
qu'est ce qu'il fait il ne pèche pas et
encore moins de l'ambient le monsieur en
fait c'est ce qu'on appelle un réfugié
climatique
il est en train de regarder son île qui
a disparu sous les eaux le réchauffement
climatique les gaz à effet de serre le
trou dans la couche d'ozone
toutes ces problématiques qui en fait on
on va dire bouleversé le climat favorisé
la montée des eaux et crée des
situations comme celle-ci et j'ai envie
de vous dire messieurs dames que ça ne
que c'est juste le début ça va ce n'est
vraiment que le début
la deuxième chose qui va à m'interpeller
c'est cette jolie mollet qu est-ce qu il
ya des chimistes dans la salle qui sait
ce que c'est aa c'est de la chlordécone
ni plus ni moins le scandale plan
déconne éclate
on y lit la chlordécone au cancer les
antillais sont tous très affectés
là je me dis ouah mais c'est pas
possible un vraiment des soucis
il ya vraiment un problème la
chlordécone le réchauffement climatique
il ya il y a quelque chose à faire
ensuite j'apprends une information 70%
70% des métaux que nous utilisons
aujourd'hui en 2040 c'est-à-dire dans 25
ans
laissons ce seront tape plus de zinc eu
plus de cuivre plus de plomb je ne sais
pas comment on va faire vos téléphones
messieurs dames c'est ça le coeur de la
question est là quel papa je sais qu'il
faut que je change de voie il faut que
je fasse de l'environnement j'ai envie
d'essayer de lutter contre tout ça mais
je ne sais pas vraiment comment je
cherche un peu la genèse
tout ça pourquoi est-ce qu'on a tous ces
soucis et au final j'ai arrive à une
conclusion assez simple en consomment
beaucoup trop des choses dont on n'a pas
besoin des choses qui au final sont en
doublons ou des choses qu'on aurait pu
économiser et puis qu'on achète quand
même et surtout on consomme vraiment mal
nous choisissons nos produits en
fonction de nos besoins certes mais nous
n'avons pas encore le réflexe de faire
des comparatifs ou ce produit a été
fabriqué comment est-ce que des enfants
sont en jeu nous ne consommons pas comme
nous pourrions le faire de façon plus
responsable et c'est à ce moment là
messieurs dames que je choisis de faire
de l'éco sociaux conception alors là ça
y est vous dit tout
elle a dit un gros mot mais en fait non
l'écho sociaux conception c'est pas
compliqué c'est de la conception
produits classiques
je répond à un besoin du consommateur en
mettant en face une solution produits ou
services simplement en répondant à son
besoin
je m'occupe des impacts écologiques et
des impacts sociaux
quand je conçois le produit que je veux
vendre j'ai bien réfléchi à ces impacts
et j'ai fait le maximum soit pour les
faire disparaître en fait soit pour les
réduire et donc ses dents ça que je me
lance messieurs dames pendant quatre ans
j'avais faire de l'éco conception dans
une entreprise en essayant de vendre des
produits plus responsable
l'éco-conception en fait à fonctionner
sur plusieurs niveaux
le premier celui que j'appelle la
durabilité un produit en fait qu'on
pourra réutiliser qui va durer plusieurs
années
c'est un produit durable j'aime beaucoup
l'exemple du bureau donc ce sont des
bureaux qui sont conçus pour faire
glisser les tablettes faits remontent
échelle et c'est un bureau qu'on pourra
utiliser de trois ans à 18 ans oui vous
pouvez trouver des bureaux pour vos
enfants qui vont faire de l'enfance à
l'âge adulte
et ça c'est un produit durable le
deuxième pilier vraiment importante
d'éco conception
c'est ce qu'on appelle la multifonction
j'aime bien cet exemple parce que c'est
une table qui a trois fonctions
la première la table à manger de tous
les jours on peut y manger à quatre
familles moyennes la deuxième il y a
deux extensions vous pouvez l'utiliser à
8 à 10 c'est une table pour recevoir et
la dernière fonction une fois que vous
avez plié la table c'est une table basse
une table de salon et ça messieurs dames
ce sont des impacts d'une table / 3 il
n'y a plus de déchets le mot déchets est
banni du dictionnaire que des sous
produits
qu'est ce qu'ils ont sous produits
typiquement c'est le résidu le reste
d'une production qu'on a réussi à
valoriser
on crée de la valeur ajoutée à partir de
ce qu'on a appelé un déchet il ya un
exemple extrêmement intéressant
martinique c'est celui du revêtement de
surface créés à partir des troncs de bel
ami quand la récolte est finie on a
récupéré toutes les bananes le trou
ordinairement c'est un déchet
aujourd'hui les tronçons valoriser en
revêtement de surface ça c'est
particulièrement fort en éco-conception
et c'est vraiment je pense
des exemples qui vous montrent qu'à
c'est possible
quel écho conception fonctionne je
travaille donc pendant quatre ans sur
ces sujets mais vous savez quoi ça ne
fonctionne pas je vous ai présenté tout
ce qu'on peut faire en éco-conception là
vous vous dites waouh c'est super mais
dans la pratique ça n'a pas marché
pourquoi selon moi un problème de
communication
au final aujourd'hui
le consommateur est d'avant ça ecolabel
européen
non mais française la belle forêt
durable label imprim'vert les labels les
étiquettes
il y en a des centaines qui est capable
de me dire ce qu'il y a derrière chacune
d'entre elles qui les comprend qui sait
les lire et qui sait choisir en fonction
de ces étiquettes c'est le coeur du
problème les produits sont là mais on
n'a pas encore réussi à communiquer
suffisamment avec le consommateur pour
qu'il change sa consommation
au final aujourd'hui après y avoir
beaucoup réfléchi j'ai envie de vous
dire qu'il ne nous reste qu'un pas à
faire libérer ceux que j'appelle les
côtes transparence alors là encore c'est
un concept mais en clair il y a deux
choses la première chose c'est réveiller
les consciences des consommateurs depuis
plusieurs années beaucoup de gens
sensibilise beaucoup de gens parlent à
nous consommateurs et j'ai envie de dire
que ce lavier il est déjà presque
activée il ya déjà beaucoup de gens qui
font attention à ce qu'ils achètent
pourquoi ils achètent
comment ils achètent et je suis sûr que
parmi vous il y en a et la deuxième
chose
à l'ère de la troisième révolution
industrielle au moment où on parle d'
usine du futur
qu'est ce que c'est l usine du futur une
usine responsable une usine centré sur
l'humain et une usine connectés
connectés par les réseaux connectés par
internet connectées par l'open data
l'open data la donne est ouverte
la donne et transparente la donne est
libre une fois que les entreprises ont
intégré cet éco transparence une fois
qu'elle sera dans leur stratégie
une fois qu'on saura tout tout tout sur
le produit là à ce moment là les
consommateurs pourront choisir
vous êtes vous déjà demandé pourquoi les
ces missions comme enquête exclusive
capital m6 investigations tout tous et
tous ces documentaires en fait ont un
point commun c'est qu'on nous dit tout
et vous avez déjà sûrement eu ce réflexe
waouh je savais pas que c'était s'était
fabriqué comme ça moi je vais plus
jamais en acheter ben je suis sûr que si
on faisait l inverse si on était
transparent si on disait d'où venaient
les choses comment elle s'était fabriqué
par qui pourquoi et bien les gens aient
le réflexe inverse il dirait à oui ça se
produit j'ai envie de l'acheter
je sais qu'il a été fait de façon
responsable qu'il fait fonctionner
l'économie locale qu'il fait travailler
les gens dans mon quartier là se produit
je peux l'acheter et donc messieurs
dames
c'est ça que j'avais envie de vous dire
aujourd'hui que l'écho transparence
n'est qu'à un pas d'être libéré elle le
sera quand nous consommateurs nous
exigerons de savoir ce que nous achetons
nous exigerons de comprendre d'où
viennent les produits
comment ils ont été faits à cette veille
de noël
vous allez recevoir des cadeaux je vous
invite à vous poser la question le
cadeau que j'ai reçu d'où il vient
comment il a été fabriqué et si c'était
à refaire
est ce que je leur achèterait merci
beaucoup